>> THANKS, ANDY.
BRET: LET’S BRING IN BACK CHRIS
WALLACE, DANA PARINO, JUAN
WILLIAMS, COHOST TO HAVE FIVE.
CHRIS, NOW WE START TO LOOK
FORWARD, RIGHT, IN THIS
TRANSITION TIME IS A TIME WHEN
THE BIDEN CAMP WILL START
PLAYING THE PARLOR GAME OF WHO
IS GOING TO BE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE, WHO IS GOING TO BE
FILLING OUT THE CABINET.
YOU’RE ALREADY HEARING LIKE
MICHELLE AT THE PENTAGON, THE
FIRST POSSIBLE FEMALE DEFENSE
SECRETARY.
THIS IS WHERE WE WILL BE SHORTLY
EVEN AS THE LEGAL CHALLENGES ARE
GOING FORWARD.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE ARE TOLD NOW THAT ON MONDAY
THE FIRST THING THAT PRESIDENT
ELECT BIDEN IS GOING TO DO IS
NAME A CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
AND -- AND TO BASICALLY MAKE THE
MESSAGE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
CHIEF OF STAFF AND MORE
IMPORTANT THAN CABINET POSITION
THAT IS YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT, IS
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE THIS COVID
CRISIS FACING THE COUNTRY
SERIOUSLY AND WE ARE GOING TO
DEAL WITH IT AND I THINK YOU’RE
GOING SEE THEM ROLL OUT SOME
POLICY IDEAS, SOME PERSONNEL
IDEAS AND MAKE IT CLEAR, YOU
KNOW, REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
PRESIDENT DOES, THEY’RE MOVING
FULL AHEAD IN THESE CLOSING
MOMENTS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE THING,
THE POWER OF WHAT WE ARE SEEING
RIGHT NOW, YOU HAD ARI AND MARC,
TO RED REPUBLICAN FIGHTERS AND
THEY BEGAN THEIR APPEARANCES
HERE TONIGHT -- TODAY ON FOX
SAYING, CONGRATULATIONS TO
PRESIDENT ELECT JOE BIDEN, HERE
WE HAVE ON FOX THE BOTTOM OF THE
SCREEN, JOE BIDEN ELECTED 46TH
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ON FOX.
YOU SEE THESE -- THE CROWDS
CELEBRATING IN THE STREETS OF
NEW YORK AND OTHER CITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, THERE’S A TREMENDOUS
MOMENTUM.
WE JUST CALLED THIS RACE JUST
BEFORE NOON.
IT’S JUST BEFORE 2:00 IN THE
EAST NOW AND THERE’S A
TREMENDOUS MOMENTUM THAT’S
ALREADY PICKING UP THAT JOE
BIDEN IS THE DUALLY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAY BE DIGGING
IN HIS HEELS AND MAY HAVE HIS
LAWYERS OUT, BUT, YOU KNOW,
THERE WAS A FICTIONAL BARTENDER
NAMED MR. DUALLY AT THE TURN TO
HAVE CENTURY AND FAMOUS SAID A
QUOTE THAT LIVED LONG AFTER THE
STORIES THAT SAID THE SUPREME
COURT FOLLOWS THE ELECTION
RETURNS AND YOU HAVE TO THINK
WITH ALL OF THIS MOMENT --
MOMENTUM BUILDING UP IN THE
COUNTRY AND IN THE NEWS MEDIA,
IT’S GOING TO BE AWFULLY HARD
FOR ANY JUDGE LET ALONE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE TO PUT THEIR FOOT
IN THE DOOR UNLESS THERE’S VERY
STRONG EVIDENCE OF INDUSTRIAL
STRENGTH ELECTION FRAUD AND